how old was your dad when he found out
he had terminal cancer
i think he was 48
if memory serves
um
yeah i think he was around 48
and he got diagnosed with renal cell
carcinoma which is a kidney cancer he
removed a soft ball-sized tumor off his
kidney
um
he was a vegetarian didn't drink didn't
smoke you know had a pretty healthy
lifestyle but just gotten out of a
really bad multi-year lawsuit
that caused a lot of stress which
probably
probably helped out a lot i'm sure
um
but yeah it was at the time they had
given him eight months
and so we pushed up our wedding and
everything he ended up lasting eight
years
he was a fighter for sure
he definitely fought
uh tooth and nail
and so ended up lasting about eight
years on it which was great
and where were you when you found out
it's funny i actually remember exactly
where i was i was working at the video
superstore in orlando florida
and he called while i was on a shift and
i were going out and sitting in the car
on my lunch break i think and he told me
about it i remember yeah i remember very
vividly
um
and it was just kind of like oh
okay
you know this
this big hit of
of what uh
you know kind of kind of re-eva how did
you re-evaluate your lifestyle and your
life at that point because you're kind
of like oh wow okay and rich really
realize really quickly how sacred life
is
for sure
but i remember sitting in my 88 suburban
in that parking lot when he called
and told us and it was like oh
okay
and then trying to figure out what to do
from there
and when you walked back into the store
did the store look different
in a way because your perspective
now everything was turned upside down
i don't know if necessarily my
perspective was completely turned upside
down it was more so of
okay
okay like what do we do next what's the
next step i'm definitely a very
structured kind of person so it's like
all right if i have to accomplish
something what do i have to do to get
there
like okay what's next we do surgery next
okay we do the surgery remove the tumor
okay then once after that then we start
chemotherapy okay so like what's the
plan to get to our goal of
remission
so i think my mind was kind of more
thinking that way
than
thinking about oh
i'm gonna go cry for an hour and a half
you know
and be sad i think it was more so about
okay here we are what do we have to do
to accomplish our goal to make to make
this work to make this better
um
which of course you only have so much
say in
because it's
uh it's a disease but
uh and then they started the processes
and
you stuck around for another eight years
it was crazy
it was cool
how did that day impact his life and how
did that day impact yours he definitely
made a lot of choices and changes
after that he
moved back to his home state of
louisiana
he got closer to family over there
he ended up meeting
a woman beth who they start a
relationship and she had a big farm and
he started a farm which he never had a
farm before we bought him goats for
christmas i remember her sheep
sheep sheep and goats because that was
fun and she started this farm
he was a lawyer and a judge for
uh years and so
he kind of took to this retirement he
would have to go to houston to do
chemotherapy and through the md anderson
center
and um
then after a few of those years he
started traveling you know trying to
travel to places that he hadn't been to
he tried to
kind of live live the best he could he
got remarried during that to beth and
you know lived as much as he could
possibly do
but it was interesting because at the
end
i have two of my sisters and i went and
stayed with them two weeks apart so we
each had two weeks with them
and i had the last two weeks and i was
leaving because our short 222 was
playing at grumman's chinese theater
here in hollywood which was the first
time i'd ever had a movie play in
hollywood let alone at the chinese
theater it was a huge huge deal
and
i was there with him for two weeks and
then i took a flight to hollywood i met
my wife she flew out from florida we
went to this whole red carpet had this
whole incredible experience got meetings
from studios and all this different
stuff i put her back on a flight the
next day because i had set up a few days
worth of meetings while i was there
and as soon as she got on the flight and
left i remember going back and i was
just hanging out just looking at the
hollywood sign soaking everything in
and then i get a call saying he's not
going to last the next day
so it was really crazy experience it was
like the highest and lowest point i
think i'd ever experienced in the same
time frame
and so i was like well
okay and so i went and booked a flight
you know flew back to the small town
louisiana that he was in
cancelled all my meetings cancelled
everything
and um and yeah he passed away the next
day and so it was a crazy
whirlwind for sure um
and what's what's even crazier is uh
three months after that my stepbrother
ended up getting killed by an accidental
shooting and three months after that my
wife's mother died of cancer
so it was a very crazy year
um
and also our son was born right after
she passed away a few months after she
passed he was born
but it really
going back to the whole horror element
it really lit a fire
to where it's like all right you know
your life is not guaranteed tomorrow's
not guaranteed like you've got to get
going you got to make sure that
everything you're doing
is impacting the way that you want to go
and to help you reach this goal that
you've set for yourself
and so
you know soon after that we moved out
here and and kind of changed where we
were doing things and it's it's been
great it's been wonderful but it's that
fire that kind of keeps keeps pushing um
because yeah it's you never know you
know and i've had friends that have
passed away that are younger than me and
stuff and even during covet like we've
had friends pass away from covid that
you know just didn't get
had their whole chance taken from them
and so like you see that and it's like
oh my gosh
you know and then your monster really
goes crazy
because it doesn't want to die either
and
you really kind of got to figure out
what's what's the best plan you know to
get what you want and where you want to
be
and
once you decalculate all that i feel
like you you use your secret decoder
ring and see how the industry works and
you're kind of like okay this makes
sense this makes sense this makes sense
you see what connects the dots it does
make it a little easier
but it's still pretty hard
when you talked about a passion a
passionate filmmaker versus an obsessed
filmmaker
do at times you check yourself because
you realize wait a minute okay i've seen
somebody who was who had a thriving
career and and other people that i've
known pass away
how much is this really worth obsessing
over
i'm definitely a workaholic like i like
being busy i like having a lot of stuff
going on at the same time
um
though i get frazzled also too because
of it
and i have a family i have an 11 year
old son so
it's trying to find that that work-life
balance of
being there for your family and then
also continuing to push
to be able to get to where you want to
be
and it's definitely challenging at times
there's some i mean i just went away for
i was six weeks on the road uh doing
shoots and then had to go home for some
family stuff for a couple weeks and so
even though it was like six weeks away
from home is is tough and then you're
trying to figure out okay well i've got
two hours a night of down time that i
could try to write something or try to
put something else together like while
i'm on this trip or i'm on a plane for
five hours we'll kind of get done while
i'm on the plane
which most of the time you just watch
movies because you're exhausted and you
don't you don't want to do anything
but it's it's trying to find that
balance and
and also still enjoying things you know
you don't want to work yourself to death
to where you're 80 years old looking
back being like
oh man i shouldn't have
you know killed myself writing those 37
scripts when i could have just gone out
and gone camping for the weekend or
something with my family
and
i think it's important to find that to
find that balance it's not always easy
to find it
but you're always trying you're always
trying to find it i think
do you ever think about when you turn 48
i know you have many years to go before
that happens oh my gosh no no i didn't
think about that till now but oh my god
i've got eight years you know for
anybody who's had a parent pass away
it's a weird thing that when you become
their age when they pass away it's like
this weird perspective that i don't know
maybe i'm just the only one that thinks
that no no i'm terrified no i didn't
even think about that until you just
brought it up oh well no
no no i mean and just in a way of you
just see life in an interesting way and
it doesn't have to be tragic actually
well interesting too my mother was
diagnosed with cancer the month after i
was born
at 20.
and she had hodgkin's disease luckily
which is the most curable kind of cancer
but the amount of chemotherapy she went
through in 1981
has caused a lot of damage on her body
now later in life
so now she's 61 and her heart is
completely falling apart she has a lot
of really bad heart problems
and her heart's way too damaged for a
transplant or anything else like that
too
so now you kind of watch that side as
well and you're like okay you're trying
to balance
you know everything else too with that
and how much time you have left with
them
and what you can do to
it's kind as a child you know you're
always trying to figure out what you can
do to make your parents proud of you
right
um
so you kind of always have that in mind
too that it's like okay while she's
still here like what can you do to be
like hey look i just did this thing
that you know maybe they're impressed by
so you know they don't know about
everything so it's sometimes it's hard
to impress you like oh i got this thing
happens i don't know what that is like
okay cool
but
i do remember the first time my movie
came in a store and i called my dad my
dad was always he was very skeptical of
everything and he was skeptical of like
everyone's skeptical the film industry
when their kids go into it because they
don't understand it they don't
understand how it works they understand
there's lots of work and you can make
lots of money and there's lots of
different things about it
um i mean it took my
my wife's parents forever to figure out
i don't know you know they've still
figured it out like what exactly we do
and how we survive but
i remember calling my dad and being like
hey the movie came out today it's like
oh okay i was like no no it's a best buy
you can go buy it and he's like what are
you talking about i'm like no it's on
the shelf like go you can go to best buy
and pick it up and he called me an hour
later and he's like you're not going to
believe this your movie's at best buy
and i'm like i just told you that like
you didn't he didn't believe me i guess
and he was like i just bought every copy
and i'm like well great i know nobody
else can watch
it uh
but it's moments like that that you know
you want
you want of course you want your parents
to be proud of you and and
my mom's my biggest cheerleader she's
awesome she's
i do a lot of horror stuff so it's like
she can't always promote everything to
her friends but
at least now the new documentary she can
um
but yeah i mean you're always trying to
find that
that approval from
peers and family and friends and
everything i think
do you think it made you grow up faster
i mean
just i was
when i grew up in high school i was the
oldest of seven kids
my dad and mom divorced and remarried
and i had three step siblings
and a half sister and so i was the
oldest of seven
so i felt then that i grew up really
quickly and i always had more than one
job
like i started working at 16
not that i had to work i just like to
work i like to be busy
so i was working at the movie theater
the video store the film commission and
the tv station all at the same time
and in the keys
the keys are 180 miles long people don't
realize how big they are so i was
driving around four hours a day i drive
an hour north to school two hours down
to key west to work and then an hour
home every night
um which is fun in l.a because someone's
like oh i don't want to drive 20 minutes
like oh i'll drive the other side of the
city it doesn't bother me
two hour drive sure um
but it's
i forget where we were going with that
that's funny because the people i don't
wanna drive over the hill i don't wanna
go over you know laurel canyon and it's
like
okay
you showed up on meetings around lunch
time
make the meetings at noon so you don't
have to drive in 9 a.m traffic
well anytime in l.a is um there's
traffic it's all pretty bad yeah yeah
what else did your dad teach you in his
final years
i mean i think the things i learned most
from him in those final years was
that life is
not guaranteed you know tomorrow's not
guaranteed and
seeing him get more and more
dehabilitated and start once the cancer
spread to his brain
and he didn't really understand
like who you were all the time or what
exactly was going on all the time
i think it was really like oh man like
you really need to get your life
together and figure out
how
to accomplish your goals i think in
entertainment people are kind of like oh
i want to be this but they never really
think about how to be that they just
assume at some point someone calls you
and you're like hey i saw this short
film you did you're awesome do you want
to direct the next avengers movie
which of course would be amazing but it
doesn't really work that way
so you got to try to figure out how to
get to the point that you want and
everyone's points different i mean some
people want to go and be a makeup artist
on a certain television show or somebody
wants to go and design props for
something else and
there's different ways to do everything
there's no
there's no right way to do anything in
the entertainment industry but there are
consistent ways that people have been
become successful
so i think it's really
i think one of the things that i've
learned that those last few years was to
really laser focus like exactly what i
wanted
and then figure out the combination to
be able to get to there as fast as i
could
um
he
he and i didn't always see eye to eye he
was definitely a person that
didn't understand
a lot
like he wanted me to play football
i can't play football i can't i'm like
the least athletic person ever um
but he played football so it's like he
wanted me to play football
though
he wanted to be a writer and his parents
didn't want to do that so he had to do
what his parents wanted and luckily he
didn't force that on me but
it was just kind of a
a different mentality
so
you always kind of have that
besides the creature living in your back
you have this little nagging thing that
always wishes that you had a little bit
more time with him
that you could have done something that
he would have been impressed by
and for me
my specific one was he was always
obsessed with france with paris he loves
france he always he went there
in college like backpacking like he
always want to go back to france
and then
three months after he died
our short gun in the cans film festival
oh wow and i'm like that was it that was
the moment that's the one i would have
had where he would have been like wow
you actually accomplished something
and you know that was taken away and i
never got to have that moment and i feel
like that will be over my head until the
day i die that one nagging thing which
is really unfortunate but
you know that's also something that's
driving you to work harder and to get
there quicker and to make it work
because now i have a son
and i can encourage him to do what he
wants to do and
he's awesome so he's we're literally
clones of each other like i feel
terrible for my wife she has two of us
now
but
he is he's amazing and
what the world gives now to kids is
incredible because when i was a kid i
didn't have robotics programs in third
grade like we didn't have all these
awesome programs and website we have
websites or anything to learn from and
he can do anything he wants like he's he
built his own robots at five years old
and he's gotten now he's really into
molecular biology
which is interesting he's 11.
obsessed with molecular biology
loves dissecting he just dissected nine
animals last year
just he loves exploring and science and
everything and it's really exciting to
to go on that journey with him and
encourage him to do you know whatever he
wants and hopefully
you know he won't have that
moment looming over his head at some
point in life that he didn't think he
had made his father proud and so that's
a that's
something else i learned as a father now
to try to work out with my son